dc comics has a number of technological
artifacts that are
fundamentally important to understanding
many of its greatest stories
chief among them are the mother boxes
from their mythical origins to their
incredible powers
here's everything you need to know about
dc's mother boxes
before you can understand mother boxes
it's useful to take a detour to
understand dc's
new gods about 18 billion years ago
there was a world named
god world as the planet evolved humanoid
beings sprang forth and developed
vastly powerful abilities over billions
of years
eventually they became gods aka the old
gods
god world fell into internal conflict
between factions of gods
culminating in god world's destruction
and a
massive wave of energy the god wave
spreading throughout the universe
the remnants of god world itself
eventually turned into two distinct
planets
on the one hand there's utopian new
genesis
ruled by the virtuous high father on the
other there's the evil
and dark apocalypse where tyranny and
war reign
these planets become home to a new set
of deities the new gods the new gods of
new genesis are of course
generally wise and just those on
apocalypse who eventually come to be
ruled by the tyrant dark side
are devoted to universal conquest and
tyranny under his malevolent
act each planet has developed
considerably advanced science and
technologies but
the most unique and complex inventions
of the new gods are the mysterious
mother boxes
the sentient super computers that can do
nearly
anything mother boxes owe their
existence to the new gods that inhabits
new genesis
specifically new genesis scientist
jaimon develops the mother boxes as
small
portable sentient supercomputers and as
for haimon he becomes the headmaster of
the academy of higher conscience
before eventually living undercover on
apocalypse
and fomenting rebellion against darkseid
as sentient technology each mother box
is its own unique entity
and has an independent will of its own
and
they get their name for the
unconditional motherly love they have
for their users
plus mother boxes were made as a result
of experiments with the mysterious
element
x dc's 10th metal which can be
manipulated by thought alone
and which powers most new god technology
element x first appeared in new gods
number seven
in effect the whole multiverse is a very
diluted form of this tenth metal
and access to the metal grants powers
beyond comprehension
and since the mother boxes come from
experiments involving element x
these devices are incredibly dangerous
while it's admittedly mysterious how
exactly they work
mother boxes are also known to have
connection to the source
the literal source of all that exists
and the infinite energy that produced
all life in the universe she is a living
computer connected to the source
their complexity means that they can't
truly be made by beings outside new
genesis or apocalypse
and very few new gods have ever been
able to successfully create them
it's even said that the creator's
personality becomes a part of the
resulting mother box
making them one of the dc universe's
most mysterious artifacts
mother boxes are enormously powerful
artifacts
as such their potential is maybe
limitless
and certainly wide-ranging and they've
been utilized by the new gods for nearly
any purpose you can imagine mother boxes
have been used to amplify their users
own powers to considerable degrees
and it doesn't seem to matter much what
those powers are
among the myriad powers mother boxes
have displayed
they've manipulated a host's mental
state allowed telepathic communication
sustained life in hostile environments
returned hosts to life
healed fatal injuries transferred energy
and changed an area's gravity on various
occasions
mother boxes can interact with
technology allowing them to control or
evolve said technology with little
effort
they've even transmuted matter and
energy
or even manipulated dimensions and
merged independent beings
into a composite being they are indeed
effectively limitless perhaps their most
famous use however is as space-bending
transportation devices
mother boxes create extra dimensional
transit tunnels
boom tubes that allow transit through
space
while mother boxes originate from the
new gods of new genesis
father boxes emerge as a similar
technology from apocalypse
albeit with an opposite moral alignment
father boxes first appear in 2001's
orion
vol 1 number 8. they were originally
introduced by darkseid's wife
mortalla as a gift to the heroic orion
evidently presented to replace his
defunct mother box
that of course was a ruse it was
actually intended to bring orion back
under darkseid's control whereas a
mother box is said to be
good loving caring and are attributed a
maternal energy in comic lore
a father box is said to have a pure evil
persona
and is crafted to have male programming
father boxes exhibit most of the varied
uses that mother boxes have showcased in
the comics
including a connection to the source
however where mother boxes are attached
to the creative
living positive good aspects of the
source father boxes access the more
negative portion of the source energies
related to its anti-life aspect
although mother boxes and father boxes
are the most prominent examples of the
new god sentient technology
there are also rare examples of stranger
boxes that serve similar functions
however their natures and backstories
are different from your standard mother
and father boxes the first of these is
the so-called orphan box
created by father time the mysterious
immortal leader of shade
a governmental organization that uses
super-powered individuals to fight
terrorism
father time himself has powers as he is
immortal
possesses super strength and his body
regenerates although it's unclear if he
is in fact a new god
regardless he creates the orphan box
from the remnants of gonzo the
mechanical bastard a being created by
apocalypse's math magicians of the
anti-life equation to spread chaos on
earth
additionally one future timeline
presented in the jla rock of ages
storyline
sees one of darkseid's torturous minions
granny goodness
turned into an insane computer called
alternately either
a grandmother box or more succinctly a
granny box
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite comic book moments are
coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one